hello and welcome to kubernetes
architecture from simply line we're
going to take a deep dive into the
kubernetes architecture if you're new to
kubernetes we already have an
introduction that goes and provides an
overview of kubernetes and we have the
link below so you can go straight to
that everyone's have a refresher
otherwise hang around and join us in
this presentation and if you want to see
more of these videos hit the subscribe
button and if you want to get notified
hit the notification bell and every time
we post up a new video you'll get the
notification right onto your phone or on
your desktop that the new video has been
uploaded and as always if you have any
questions please post them in the
comments below we do read the question
so we try to respond to all of them as
quickly as we can with that said let's
jump into kubernetes architecture so
we're gonna break out the presentation
into the following areas we're gonna
cover what kubernetes is and why you
want to be using it we're gonna
introduce the actual architecture and
provide an overview of how it contains
the containers and the other components
that you'd have within the architecture
we'll also compare communities with
docker swamp and one of the things that
you hear with kubernetes almost in the
same breath is darker and we have to be
careful not to confuse darker from a
container point of view and docker swarm
which is a container management tool and
kubernetes is also a container
management also compare the two of those
and then we look at the hardware and
software components and then finally do
a deep dive into the architecture of
kubernetes and provide a case study of
where kubernetes has been used
successfully in the past so let's jump
into this so what actually is kubernetes
so kubernetes is a tool that was
designed to actually help manage and
contain large groups of containers it
was developed originally by Google out
of the Google book absolution and then
open sourced by Google the actual
environment allows you to manage large
groups of containers so if you're a
developer in DevOps and you're working
with docker
then you're used to the concept of the
container and you'll also know that
containers and cloud technologies tend
to be almost breathed in the same breath
so the work that you're doing with
kubernetes
to be able to manage large groups of
containers inside of the cloud the thing
that's great about working with
kubernetes is that it is incredibly
flexible and allows you to have
incredibly complex applications run
efficient efficiently so let's step into
why you'd want to use kubernetes so a
couple of key points kubernetes itself
is an open source solution originally
developed by Google but it is available
on most cloud platforms today so AWS
Google cloud Microsoft Azure all of them
support kubernetes and what you'll find
is as you're setting up your
infrastructure particularly if you're
using containers you'll see that the
support in kubernetes
is floated up very very efficiently and
effectively by all three vendors it's
extremely um useful for being a to
manage large modular environments and
that's really kind of these I think one
of the big benefits of kubernetes is its
modularity is that it really breaks down
containers into their smaller parts and
once you do that it becomes much more
efficient for you as an administrator to
be able to manage that entire
environment the reproductive ility of
kubernetes extremely high you can build
out infrastructures very quickly and
have them be able to imagine that have
containers coming on and off killed and
created to be able to help load bands
reach our environment and so again you
know we keep talking about containers
but that's really what kubernetes is all
about is being able to manage your
applications that are commands through
containers and being able to do that in
a virtualized infrastructure and I think
that's also really good with the
kubernetes is it's really easy to point
solutions you just have to use a simple
curl call and you can actually push out
your kubernetes infrastructure so let's
have an overview of the kubernetes
architecture so kubernetes is really
broken up into three key areas you have
your work session where you develop your
commands and you push out those commands
to your master and the master is
comprised of four key areas which
essentially control all of your note and
the note contains multiple pods and each
part has your docker container
built into it so consider that you could
have a really almost an infinite number
of pods
that's very infinite number of
nodes are being managed by the master
environment so you have your cluster
which is a collection of servers they
maintain the availability and the
compute power such as RAM CPU and disk
utilization and you have the master
which is really components that control
and schedule the activities of your
network and then you have the node which
actually hosts the actual doctor virtual
machine itself and be able to actually
control and communicate back to the
master the health of that pod and we'll
get into more detail Meowth should take
jet later in the presentation so you
know you keep hearing me talk about
containers but they really are the
center of the work that you doing with
kubernetes and can they concept around
kubernetes in containers is really just
a natural evolution of where we've been
with internet and digital technologies
over the last 10 15 years
so before kubernetes you had tools where
you are the reigning virtual machines or
you're running data centers that had to
maintain and manage and notify you of
any interruptions in your network
kubernetes is the tool that aji comes in
and helps address those interruptions
and manages them for you so the solution
to this is the use of containers so you
can think of containers as that natural
evolution from you know 15 20 years ago
you would have written your code and
posted it to a data center more recently
you probably post your code to a virtual
machine and then move the virtual
machine and now you actually just work
directly into a container and everything
is self-contained and can be pushed out
to your environment and the thing that's
great about containers they're their
isolate environments very easy for
developers to work in them but it's also
really easy for operations teams to be
able to move a container into production
so let's kind of step in and back and
look at a competing product - kubernetes
which is docker swarm now one of these
we have to remember is that docker
containers which are extremely popular
I'm built by the company daughter and
made open source and docker actually has
other products one of those other
is docker swarm and docker swamp is a
tool that allows you to be able to
manage multiple containers so if we look
at some of the the benefits of using
docker swarm versus kubernetes one
things that you'll find is that both
tools have strengths and weaknesses but
it's really good that they're both out
there because it helps keep they did
really kind of justifies the importance
of having these kind of tools so
kubernetes was designed originally from
the ground up to be auto scaling where
suckas form isn't the load balancing is
automatic on docker swamp whereas with
kubernetes you have to manually
configure load balancing across your
nodes the installation for docker swarm
is really fast and easy I mean you can
be up and running within minutes
kubernetes takes a little bit more time
is a little bit more complicated
eventually you'll get there I mean it's
not like it's gonna take you days and
weeks but it's it is a tool that's a
when you compare the two dr. storms much
easier to get up and running now what's
interesting is that kubernetes is
incredibly scalable and it's you know
that's it's it's real strength is its
ability have strong clusters whereas
with doctors for miss Custer strength
isn't as strong when compared to
kubernetes now you compare it to
anything else on the market it's really
good so this is kind of a splitting
hairs kind of comparison but kubernetes
really does have the advantage here if
you're looking at the two compared to
each other for scalability kubernetes
was designed for by Google to scale up
and support Google cloud network
infrastructure they both allow you to be
able to stamp share and storage volumes
with Donkin you can actually do it with
any container with that is managed by
the docker swamp whereas with kubernetes
it manages their storage with the podge
and a pod can have multiple containers
within it but you can take it down to
the level of the container interestingly
kubernetes does have a graphical user
interface for being able to control and
manage the environment the reality
however is that you're likely to be
using terminal to actually make the
controls and commands to control your
either docker swarm or kubernetes
environment
it's great that it has a GUI and to get
you started but once you're up and
running you're gonna be using terminal
window for those fast quick
administrative controls that you need to
make so let's look at the hardware
components for kubernetes so what's
interesting is that kubernetes is
extremely light of all the systems that
we're looking at it's extremely
lightweight its allows you to have
compared to like a virtual machine which
is very heavy it you know kubernetes is
extremely lightweight and how they uses
any resources at all interesting enough
is that if you are looking at the usage
of CPU it's better to actually take it
for the cluster as a whole rather than
individual nodes because the nodes were
combined together to give you that whole
compute power again this is why
kubernetes works really well in the
cloud where you can do that kind of
activity rather than if you're running
in your own data center so you can have
persistent volumes such as a local SSD
or you can actually attach to a cloud
data storage again kubernetes is really
designed for the cloud I would encourage
you to use cloud storage wherever
possible rather than relying on physical
storage the reason being is that if you
connect to cloud storage and you need to
flex your your storage the cloud will do
that for you I mean that's just an
inherent part of why you'd have cloud
storage whereas if you're connecting to
physical storage you are always
restricted to the limitations of the
physical hardware so that's done kind of
pivot and look at the software
components as compared to the hardware
components so the main part of the
components is the actual container and
all of the software running and the
container
runs on Linux of you have documents
stored as develop on your machine it's
actually running inside of Linux and
that's what makes it so lightweight and
really one of these that you'll find is
that most data centers and cloud
providers now are running predominantly
on Linux inside IBM the container itself
is then managing side of a part and a
part is really just a group of
containers bundles together and then the
kubernetes scheduler and proxy server
with an 18-man
what how the pods are actually pushed
out into your kubernetes environment the
the pods themselves can actually then
share resources both networking and
storage so pods aren't pushed out
manually they're actually managed
through a layer of abstraction and part
of their deployment and and this is the
strength of kubernetes you use you
define your infrastructure and then
kubernetes will then manage you for you
and there isn't that problem of manual
management of pods if you have to manage
the deployment of them and you that's
simply taken away and it's completely
automated and the the final area of
software services is on ingress and this
is really the secure way of being able
to have communication from outside of
the cluster and passing of information
into that cluster and again this is done
security through SSL layers and allows
you to ensure that security is at the
center of the work that you have within
your kubernetes environment so let's
dive now into the actual architecture
before we start looking at a use case of
how kubernetes is being employed so
kubernetes again is we looked at this
diagram at the beginning of the
presentation and there are really three
key areas there's the workstation where
you develop your commands and then you
have your master environment which
controls the scheduling communication
and the actual commands that you have
created and pushes those out and manages
the health of your entire node network
and each node has various pods so we
like break this down so the master node
is the most vital component with the
master you have four key control 0 etc
controller manager schedule and API
server the cluster store etc this ecchi
measured the details and values that
you've developed on your local
workstation and then we'll work with the
outlet control scheduling PI server to
communicate that out those instructions
of how you infrastructure should look
like to your entire network the control
manager is it really an API server and
again this is all about security so we
use restful api which can be packaged in
ssl to
Munich ate back and forth across your
parts and the master and indeed the
services within each of them as well so
at every single layer abstraction the
communication is secure the schedule as
the name would imply really schedules
and when tasks get sent out to the
actual nose themselves by the nodes
themselves are done nodes they just have
the applications running on them the
master in the stem is really doing all
of the work to make sure that your
entire network is running efficiently
and then you have the API server which
has your s commands in the communication
back and forth across your network so
that is secure and efficient so your
node environment is where all the work
that you do with your containers gets
pushed out to so a work is really a it's
a combination of containers in each
container will then logically run
together on that node so you'd have a
collection of containers on a node that
all make logical sense to have together
within each node you have docker and
this is your isolated environment for
running your container you have your
cubelet which is a service for
convenient information back and forth to
the service about the actual health of
the kubernetes node itself and then
finally you have the proxy server and
the proxy server is able to manage the
nodes the volumes the the creation of
new containers and actually helps pass
the community they beheld of the
container back up to the master to see
whether or not the containers should be
either kill stopped started or updated
so finally let's look at see where
kubernetes is being used by other
companies so you know kubernetes is
being used by a lot of companies and
they're really using it to help manage
complex existing systems so that they
can have greater performance and with
the end goal being able to delight the
customer increase value to the customer
and enhance increased value and revenue
into the organization so an example of
this is a company called Blackrock where
they actually went through the process
of implementing kubernetes so they could
so Blackrock hello Chandra they needed
to be able to have much more dynamic
access to their resources they
running complex installations on
people's desktops and it was just really
really difficult to be able to manage
their entire infrastructure so they
actually went and pivoted to using
communities and this allowed them to be
able to be much more scalable and
expansive in the in the management of
their infrastructure and as you can
imagine kubernetes was then hooked into
their entire existing system and has
really become a key part of the success
that Blackrock is now experiencing of a
very stable infrastructure and the
bottom line is that Blackrock is now
able to have confidence in their
infrastructure and be able to give back
confidence as back to their customers
through the implementation and more
rapid deployment of additional features
and services so that's our presentation
I hope you got good information about
the architecture of kubernetes out of
that again if you'd like this
presentation hit the subscribe button
and if you hit the bell button you'll be
notified when new videos are dropped if
you have any questions please post them
in the comments we have additional
training as well as simply learn where
you can find out more information about
kubernetes and actually dig deeper into
kubernetes and how it applies to the
work that you yourself may be doing
today
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here